this conference will now be recorded
okay so the conference is recorded and
we will provide the recording to you
after the session is over let me go back
to the beginning and start my
presentation here so hopefully everybody
can see my screen if you can't you can
put it on chat that you are having any
kind of issues and at the end of this
session like I said we will have a
recording and we will provide you with
the slides so the goal of today's
session is to again review the steps of
processing RNA seek data last time as
you remember we talked about
pre-processing so we talked about
adapter trimming and PCR duplicates we
talked about alignments different
methods of alignment and we used
specifically bow-tied to team alignment
to transcriptome and we talked about
quantification how do we get the table
of expression and what is it in the
table of expression and we will talk
today a little bit about normalization
and then we will switch over to
differential gene expression so will
actually talk about students t-test
p-value false discovery rate phone
change and we will look at some methods
of differential gene expression like
with edge R and D SEC to phase on you
have a question you want to ask now okay
there is a question about are anything
that you are talking about that there is
adapter and if you have two figures to
last time in their word pairs or the
process to be used in the pipeline so I
want to order the pair or the attend you
use dead wore RNA seek or I'll meet the
spec Tomek or that was the original DNA
sequencing yeah so a good question
obviously this is RNA sequencing
transcriptomics thoughts about
transcription so we are dealing with
transcriptomic data which is gene
expression so what is I mean
we are dealing with the MRA mRNA exactly
so as you remember there is the DNA the
DNA is then transcribed into mRNA and
what we measure in RNA C is expression
of those so counts of mRNA okay so this
is a good question so let me quickly
pull up something to explain briefly
this is from another another maybe this
is good to just give a quick review to
everyone what exactly are we talking
about so as we as you remember in the
last pipeline that we prepared we used
fast queue files and so this is an
example of a fast queue file it has a
record of a short read so you can see
the length is 36 today they go between
80 and 200 but these are short reads of
sequences and these are sequences of the
genome transcriptome different things
but we specifically focused on RNA so
RNA transcription works like this you
have DNA in the chromosomes right and
eventually they end up being proteins so
how does it get from chromosomes to
proteins DNA is transcribed into RNA
right and these are going to be just
sequences of RNA that later on are
transformed into mRNA messenger RNA and
then RNA is translated into proteins now
this is a more detailed view you can
look at the RNA transcription which is
what we are focused on in RNA seek and
different events happen during that
process specifically when we talk about
RNA directly transcribed from RNA from
it has everything that the DNA has just
in a different format but when RNA is
transformed into mRNA there are specific
things that happen for example the the
exons are spliced out so we have only
exons we assume that these are primarily
exons in our mRNA
and so we are actually looking at only
exons and may may be sometimes different
combinations of exons that make
different transcripts so when we talk
about RNA transcription we're really
talking about RNA transcripts and not
necessarily they are not necessarily
always exactly genes okay now another
aspect here is just to demonstrate that
you know we have for example a DNA
sequence and that DNA sequence has
positions so all of the positions of
genes are recorded in the GTF file so
genes exons and introns all of the other
positions are reported in the GTF file
and then we have this reference fasta
files and fasiq' files actually is what
is being read GTF is a reference
fastview is what is being read so what
is in the fast few files you have these
different isoforms that are
alternatively combined exons into a
sequence and and that is the mRNA
sequence and what are we trying to do we
are trying to count the reads that fall
on those sequences that fall on to those
transcripts and this is just an example
of what is inside the GTF file so we use
because this reference file to really
align everything together so does that
make sense by széll present
yes excellent so let's go back to this
presentation the end and we nee will
yeah
go ahead Raul I had a related question
yeah so when we make the library for
sequencing it's actually the DNA that
we're sequencing right I mean if you do
RNA seek no we're sequencing RNA no no I
mean when you are me the irony is
isolate not an isolated and made into a
DNA right well yes I'm a format but the
reference material is aren't it yeah
yeah yeah okay yeah that's a good
clarification so intent in terms of
library prep in the lab you do use cDNA
too because it's more stable to read so
that that is correct but the reference
material and what we are studying here
are mRNAs all right okay so what is
differential gene expression and I
assume a lot of you are already familiar
with this so it might be some
refreshment for you and what we will
talk about today is differential gene
expression and then at the end and we
want to talk a little bit about
annotation and gene set enrichment
analysis so we will talk about or try to
understand what does this mean now if
you remember in terms of our project we
used a number so actually 11 samples
right we used these reference links to
files that are already uploaded on the
server and we are looking at this as our
metadata for the samples that we're
using so we have the sequence reads so
those are the fast queue files and then
we have their subtypes so these are non
malignant or normal like and versus
cloud and lo and this is just a visual
example
since we have names of cell lines that
we are actually dealing with this is
what they look like so you can see that
they are quite different even visually
right now we let me show you this is the
pipeline so obviously some of you have
not seen the result of your own pipeline
we all have this link in the chat and
here you can always go and see in the
uploaded data these are the files that
we use so you can see that they are
paired in so we have underscore one and
two sealed what was the question
no nothing Elvis is talking to Abby I
guess it was in connection issues I'm
just talking to him sorry I referred
everyone okay all right so yeah so these
are parent files and in the end you will
get 11 files and this is the reference
table that we were looking at okay so
yeah did somebody have a question yes
from I said so you are talking about
that the uploaded file are in the pair's
form last in last where you are dealing
with the Python so we are dealing with
mRNA but mrna is a single or single
nucleotide long chain so how we can make
it in fearing I mean RNA is always in a
single so how we can make it clear right
so okay what what is meant here by pair
end is that actually the reading of each
fragment happens from both sides right
so you have a single strand of our it
has the beginning on the end the 305
fine and the reading of each read
happens from both sides so you don't
have two stranded DNA and you read two
strands separately you are reading the
same strand
read from both sides and that is the
paired end that made sense and that is
used to make it more reliable because
there are sequencing errors and because
you want to make sure that you are
reliably reading the actual sequence
okay so these are over to end reads and
this is the simple pipeline that we did
we took uploaded the files transform
them into pair them to combine them
together and then we referenced the
transcripts the known transcripts and we
prepared an expression table at the end
and what we want to look at is what is
inside the results so if you open this
folder now all of you have the link to
the pipeline I'll just paste it again
in the chat and you can go ahead and
open this pipeline and take a look at
what is inside so what do we see inside
we have a number of tables for jeans and
a number of tables for isoforms as well
as a mapping statistics table that gives
us the quality of mapping of those reads
how many of the reads were actually
mapped how many of the weeds were not
mapped and if you remember last time we
did talk about this a little bit so
today what we want to do is we want to
download this expression Gene's fpkm and
take a look at this table so if you
download this txt file this is actually
a txt file with tab delimited columns
and we already looked at this table
before but just to review that again we
have the gene name and then we have
column names which correlate with the
samples okay
so quickly you know that we can arrange
this in the right way we can now maybe
annotate this table so that we know what
we are looking at okay so
let's open this up so you can see the
full name and we can go back look what
are these samples so what are these
samples 6 8 7 if we look at 6 8 7 this
is normal like 6 8 8 is normal like six
nine seven is cloud and look so what we
can do is add another row here and we
can write that it so this is normal or
we can just say ml and now and this is
cloud as well and let's keep on going so
we have 697 then we have 703 703 is
cloud and low which is cloud and well
714 is cloud and low 7 16 is Plowden low
720 is is warmer like 7 21 is normal
like 726 is cloud and low 634 normal
like and only 636 is cloud and low so as
you can see they are not really
organized so what we did last time was
we kind of switch them around so let's
just call this group ok and now we can
take these and then we can paste them
over here and we can take this one and
we can taste it holy [ __ ]
so now what we have is all of these are
sorry all of these are normal like and
all of these are loud and low ok so now
we know that we are dealing with two
groups
does anybody know how to measure
differences between two groups of
samples hello hello yeah we can use P
test and for love full and full change
hadami there any differences between two
books excellent Thank You Pranita so
indeed what we use as a statistical test
to differentiate between these two
groups is something called
students t-test so a little bit of what
is exactly students t-test back in the
1920s there was a gentleman whose name
was william sealy gosset who invented
the students t-test and the reason he
invented this test is because they were
studying different barley crops from
which beer was produced and they wanted
to know whether there really is a
difference and how beer is made from
these different crops and so he came up
with this statistical test but he
couldn't publish it under his own name
so he used it used a pseudonym a student
and today we know this test instead of
gossip test we you know it as the
students t-test and what it really shows
is this formula so this is obviously a
simplified this is just the concept and
so it's good for us to understand this
concept a little bit the idea is that we
really want to measure a signal that is
reliable by removing the noise and what
does that mean that means that we can
compare means of groups and then we can
also include the variability of groups
so that we know that we are not randomly
selecting some value because on random
things can also appear to have a
difference but that does not mean that
it is a consistent different
so let's take a look at what exactly
that means let's take a mean of this so
this is a gene right and this is its
expression level in each sample and so
when I want to just on average look at
the expression level within this room
what I need to do is I need to take a
mean so let's do this as mean for ml and
this will be our mean for cloudy low
okay so for NL we'll just color it as
yellow and this will be our same color
orange so how do we calculate me mean is
average so average of these sorry yeah
average of these and what we need to do
is we need to put it here so what is
this number this number is the sum of
these numbers divided by the number of
these numbers so one two three four five
so all of these divided by five and all
of these divided by six so we want to do
this and then we want to do a mean of
these numbers as well sorry
average of these numbers so we know that
the on average this gene is expressed at
seven point five and on average the same
gene in this group is ten point 33
the question is whether this is really
bigger than this the answer is pretty
simple right three approximately so so
what we can do is we can just measure
what is this - for example this or we
can do this divided by this right so
those are two ways that we can measure
the difference and
when we say full change pronita said
full change actually this is full change
because we're looking at how many times
how many fold right that's the name fold
before the change is this one within
this one okay does that make sense so
far it's making sure if anybody has a
question about what we're doing so far
please ask me okay so no questions
that's good so now we want to understand
whether this or this is really a
statistically significant difference
what does that mean well what it means
is that these numbers have a certain
distribution and these numbers have a
certain distribution how can we look at
the distribution the way we look at the
distribution is by the following way so
we can insert for example a simple bar
chart and we can see that these two are
not exactly the same right for example
I'll have really small numbers you have
large numbers but you have a different
number here different number here so on
it's hard to say whether the average is
a very good way to represent the
difference because even though there's a
small maybe 1.4 fold change between the
two it might have been you know
misleading to say that this is
consistent for every single
representative example from this group
and a representative from this way so to
overcome this question we will
on a probability and the probability is
to say that we want to see whether we
have any sample from this room
significantly different from any sample
in this room and that it wouldn't happen
by chance and the way we calculate that
probability is by assuming that maybe I
would take random numbers from here and
random numbers from here and by chance
if these numbers were completely random
and these were completely random
I could still achieve this full change
okay so what we fortunately we have a
t-test function here that allows us to
create this probability value also
called p-value so what we can do is we
can take these this array of numbers and
we can take this array of numbers and
then we can do two and three and this is
our p-value so this is the probability
of this difference happening by chance
okay so if my probability of these two
being different from each other by
chance is about 38% do you think this is
a good probability that the difference
is reliable or a bad probability that
this is reliable what do you think it
right so there what do you think this
means Faison yes when we talk about the
p-value in statistics so we measure the
value with one if the probability is
less than 1 so we take it to level if
the differencing is period from 1 in key
value so we can say that the defendant
is not reliable okay well let's take a
look at this example once again let's
take some random values okay so let's
take 1/2 25 3 okay so this is just some
random numbers I put together and let's
take some completely different numbers
so 0 for 10 1 1 7 ok and let's calculate
the mean so average and average for
these X's so are these different not not
by a lot right even though the numbers
are very different inside what if I
change them to be exactly the same what
would happen they are exactly the same
now right so the fold change is equal to
0 but the numbers could be a little bit
different right so for example the mean
could be the same but the numbers could
be completely different and still the
mean is the same now the question is
whether this and this has a probability
value of being
let's take a look so this is my t-test
I'm going to take these numbers and
these numbers so the p-value is indeed 1
so it's a good p-value right it's a high
pvalue like you were saying the
probability of this happening by chance
is an absolute 100% what does that mean
about p-value it means about a p-value
that the smaller the p-value the lower
the probability of these numbers being
exactly the same or on random appearing
as a difference is close to zero and
that is what we're looking for so when
we go back to our real example and we
look at 0.38 that means that almost 40%
chance that this could happen in a
random example and we want this number
to be as low as possible
a good statistic significant p-value is
0.05 which means that about 5% of the
time this would happen by chance but 95%
we have a confidence of 95% that this
will not happen by chance okay so that
is just something to understand about
p-value so when we talk about
differential gene expression both of
these numbers are going to be important
a high full change and a low p-value so
how do we measure this let's take a look
and expect this for all of our genes so
we have now the mean for one in the mean
for the other we can calculate the full
change the difference between these
means and we can test the p-value so we
can assume that or we can measure the
variance within this group
measure the variance within this group
and make sure that on a completely
random example
this would not be a significant
difference and now we want to actually
sort all of these so let's pre-filter
and we want to sort them by first having
a high right so let's just do a high
let's do a high full change okay so all
of these are zeros and we want this um
to be low key value okay so now of
course we are also not interested in
having those that have a zero voltage so
actually so we don't want this guy okay
so the highest one let's see all right
now let
take a look at this for for a second and
see what can we see here and this goes
back to the idea of normalization
normalizing our values what you can see
here is that some values so some of
these means are very very different
okay so you get numbers like eleven
thousand something you know thousands
and the problem with that is that
thousand versus two both could have a
significant p-value but they will have a
very different weight to their meaning
let's do this for a second so let's do
custom sort so first we will sort by
full change largest to smallest and then
we will followed by p-value smallest to
largest okay so now we want to go and we
actually want to filter out so we're not
interested in full changes that have a
low or a high p-value right so here we
can actually instead do specific so here
here we want to do maybe less than or
equal to 0.05 okay and so these are all
of the p-values all of the genes that
are less than 0.05 and now we can just
scroll down and we see when the fold
change goes to I think 1.2 is probably
our cutoff
so let's find one point two is right
here and we can now select all of these
genes so let's go into poppy all of
these genes
hands face them right here okay so what
we have now is a list of genes that are
differentiated so how do we know let's
take a look at an example from the
highest one again let's insert a bar
chart and we see what that means so we
see that we have low in normally right
and high in cloud and look what about
the other way around right so could we
have a good p-value but let's go to what
what does it mean when the fold change
is zero point something let's take a
look at this gene for a second and we
can create a bar chart and this shows us
the other situation so it is again a
significant difference but it's the in
the opposite direction so when we are
actually below zero we have this other
direction so we're also interested in
those examples as well so let's go to
the zeros right so actually but let's
sort it the other way around so let's do
ascending and now the question is okay
what is the lowest value that we want to
have and so if you can look over here
the mean right so this is zero and the
mean is pretty high those are pretty
good so zero was going to be good and
and we can just take a look at below
zero point so yeah don't change
so zero point one or let's
0.2 0.2 0.2 ends up here let's copy that
and now we can add them here at the
bottom okay let's see
okay so now we have our list of genes
that are both up regulated in our cloud
and lo samples and downregulated in the
cloud in the normal like and the other
way around right so this is our example
for this account and let's take an
example from the other scenario okay so
if we take this gene as an example
and they're going to start normal boys
okay so we have these two examples this
one and this one and let's just make
sure that we remember what these samples
are
you check make sure okay I just took the
extra
so here sorry okay
there we go so now we have these two
examples of these two jeans and they are
just examples right so we have other
examples in here obviously because we
have a total of about let's see how many
we have we have about 1500 jeans now
this is really the idea of differential
gene expression there are going to be a
lot of genes that have this pattern of
expression and they're going to be a lot
of genes that have this pattern of
expression now there is a way to
automate what we just did we did this so
that we all understand what we are
talking about what we are trying to
achieve but now we want to create
another pipeline that does this for us
automatically before I move on to that
does anybody have any questions
hi yeah go ahead rola I mean I had a
question about the t-test so when we are
comparing these two set of samples are
we comparing their distributions is that
dieting we are taking into consideration
their distributions we are comparing the
mean but we are subtracting the noise so
when we talk about distribution right
how do we calculate a distribution a
distribution means that you take all of
the values present so all of these
numbers and you count how many in each
category do you have so that is called
the distribution typically we expect a
normal distribution what is a normal
distribution that means that I have a
small number of very high
numbers and a fairly small of very low
numbers and then I have a little bit
more of medium-range numbers and that
typically looks like a bell curve right
so if you broke up a normal distribution
it will look like a bell curve now in
our example we are assuming that both of
these distributions in terms of their
shape is going to be the same but we are
expecting the range to be different so
the variance within each group to be
different and because those ranges are
different that that's why we need to
have a p-value so we are taking into
consideration the range and the range
here but we are assuming a normal
distribution so that's why we are
relying on the meat because mean really
is just a representative number it
doesn't tell us anything about the
distribution does that make sense yeah
so I mean when we do a t-test or when we
get the p-value they tell us that the
distributions don't overlap or you know
they tell us no they tell us that if by
chance we had a number you know a range
of numbers and so let's say you know
they went up and down up and down up and
down they were just random numbers and
these were up and down up and down
random numbers so if we take a mean from
here and a mean from here does that mean
that these individual numbers are
actually different from these it's
impossible to say right so what so how
do we know well because these go up and
down we organized all of them so that
they go from lowest to highest
right and that gives us a sense of
distribution like you said and then we
compare the length so if we have every
number is different that's one scenario
if a lot of numbers are similar like
here these are kind of sin
right yeah that means that the
distribution is actually narrow so when
a lot of numbers are similar to each
other the distribution is narrow and
when there is a lot of different ones
that means that they are wide and so we
are taking that into consideration but
we are still checking whether the
difference that we find using the mean
is has a probability a low probability
to happen by chance
that's the p-value okay okay okay so now
let's go to the platform and take a look
at how we can use this differential
expression section right here to
calculate this not manually in Excel but
actually algorithmically using methods
that also take into consideration false
discovery rate that is another mystical
issue that we're not going to go into
very deeply because we only have a short
time left but the idea is that you will
have very many genes and because of the
number of those genes some of those
values could also be found by change
right so if you flip a coin very many
times if you find a lot of coins that
have you know some kind of a strange
result like they all fall on heads or
they all fall on tails just because you
have a lot of times that you flip the
coin that means you are falsely assuming
that the coin is faulty just because you
found let's say 50 out of a million
times that the coin flipped all the time
on its head right so that's the general
idea we're not going to go into it too
much but it takes into consideration
just the amount of genes the samples
that or the amount of genes features
that we have in this state
so let's create an RNA seek pipeline for
those of you
don't remember the SVL let me give you
the SPL again
so this is our SPL I'm going to place it
here in me in the chat message okay
let's take a look at this SPL again what
isn't time so inside we have the same
fast few files so let's go through this
again and this will both reinforce our
understanding of the pipeline and this
time we will do it actually with the
pre-processing steps as well and it will
include the differential expression okay
so now let's convert this to parent eats
fast few files do you remember what we
used last time for our reference genome
yes dead walk on there good geography at
38 exactly so the latest assembly of the
human genome and now we use this URL
both upload so we go here and we find
wherever you say do you remember that
you have to actually download the files
onto your computer to do this please
these do this with me so that we all are
on the same page and by next time I will
make sure that all of your pipelines
have finished so I'm going to take this
svl file define groups now we need to
take take a look at our table right and
we need to place the samples from one
group so normally in two group a and
cloud and low into Group B so let's drag
them so we have let me do this actually
okay so I'm going to take five six or
six eight seven which I'm going to take
six eight seven six eight seven and that
is normal life
six eight eight is also normally seven
to zero so seven to zero is normally 721
is also normally and six three four
so six three four is normally the rest
are cloud and load so I'll just drag
them right here right so we have five of
these six of these together eleven files
we do continue we do we're not going to
use contrast so it's just to select all
and now we are going to build our
pipeline so we're going to do trim o
matic trim the adapters right then we're
going to do PCR clean remove the
randomly PCR amplified reads then from
here where do we go next
can somebody tell me
freaking or you stop it for the mapping
good eats on a genome reference genome
how about transcriptome how do we map on
reference transit oh okay yeah so which
bowtie there is a bowtie right here
bowtie right here and a bowtie right you
know which one do we want to use for
mapping on transcripts the deep you eat
exactly
so prototype to team mapping on
transcripts Thank You Raoul and Pranita
so we aligned on known transcripts this
is going to save us a lot of time and
now we need to create an expression
table right so does anybody remember the
difference between these yeah if PK m
and T p.m. is what are they we remember
the fragments particular base million
and it's a it's how we do I normalize
the data by the length of the gene and
and by the total counts of the reads I
think that's how it differs its that yes
so fpkm Oh leave it yeah
and now we need to select one of the
differential expression modules so you
can choose whichever one you want tuft
if that's not available is because to
use cuffed if you actually use the whole
cuff links cuffdiff package which is
right here so you have cufflinks cuff
merge and then cuff gift but in our
example I can use for example D sex -
you can use edge bar whichever one you
want
and so you can see here how do we
actually use this method and now reading
this you should probably understand that
very well so a common difficulty in the
analysis of next-generation sequencing
data isn't
the strong variants of log full
changelog arithmetical change estimates
for jeans with low recount we
demonstrate this issue using the data
set the insect to overcomes this issue
by shrinking log fold change estimate
scored zero in a manner such that
shrinkage is stronger when they're
available information for a gene is low
which may be because counter low
dispersion is high or there are few
degrees of freedom okay so degrees of
freedom references the number of samples
that you have gene counts obviously will
have certain ones that have very small a
number of leads that fall in them or
others have very high so you take into
consideration different variables from
the data
let's I'm gonna use the insect to
somebody else could use age are from the
Talia army and I can run my pipeline
okay is everybody following this so far
yes okay excellent now this is actually
a good example sometimes as you saw I
was thinking a long time so I was
explaining what was going on and the
session closed so I have this spinning
wheel and it's not moving along and
after I see that it's not right what I
can do is I can actually be load and go
to my pipelines and you will see that
the latest pipeline that I created it is
safe it wasn't lost
but it's only prepared and so I go back
inside and now I can click on run
pipeline to actually start my pipeline
so once I click on this you'll see that
the page will reload and now you can see
that in its processing so I'll go back
to my pipelines and this is processor
now what are we expecting as a result of
the
pipeline I'm gonna try and move along
fairly quickly now because we don't have
a lot of time what we are expecting is a
result of differential expression so
here are some files that you can take a
look at in your spare time gonna things
going right here but this thing right
here so you can take a look at some of
these files so this is what I did
be set to out let's just open this in
Excel and see what is inside so what you
can see here are some familiar things
right so you have log fold change you
have p-value you have he adjusted value
and then base me and other step so what
does this mean well again we are looking
for the low p-value and you don't have
the P adjusted value that's where the
false discovery when it comes in so it's
key value adjusted by false discovery
rate and that is actually what we're
gonna use for a stringent analysis so
what we will do here is we can sort by
low p-value just like we did the other
time so let's add the filter and we will
sort by again we don't need those that
don't have a non available p-value and
we need the smallest ones first so we
have a very small p-value and now what
we can do is we can be custom sorts
expand this election so we have smaller
Stu largest and then we need to log two
fold for long to fold change this by
values and here we want the largest
piece moment okay
so now again what is less than zero or
sorry log fold change right here so less
than zero what is less than zero means
that actually this is higher than this
but now you can start seeing that for
example this gene let's copy it and go
back to our expression table and let's
try to find it so here is this gene
let's take a look at its expression
values
see that is what it looks like
okay so this is what it looks like it
looks like I am an accident near got a
little extra okay there we go so that is
what it looks like so again we are
seeing that the cloud and low is lower
than the normal light now this gene you
could find it again like we did last
time we can go to just google for
example and just look up a single gene
so let's take a look at what this
transcript is
one seven two six six okay so the common
name is PC tk3
and that is the last thing that I would
like to show you here really quickly
let's take a look again here and we can
see that we found let's see how many we
found don't we take all of these there's
a we found all right let's do this and
we actually have to filter out so we
want sorry he's adjusted value okay so
let's do
well the problem is that we do have some
yeah let's go over here I think we had
some amazed he R so it's thinking that
it's not a number so it's just to
convert this to number and now we want
to sort this or filter them so we have
less than or equal to 0.05 okay well now
we also want to you want to take this
okay let's place it right here and let's
see how many get them so we have
approximately a similar number right so
1352 and here we have 15 22 we are using
the just a p-value that is going to be
lower than your regular p-value so
actually that makes a lot of sense so if
we take all of the statistically
significant genes we get about 1300 gens
and now what we want to do is actually
understand what these genes are now
there are two ways of doing them okay so
let's just quickly finish off this
presentation and we talked about D SEC 2
and edge our rights are two methods that
you could use for differential gene
expression and now we want to talk a
little bit about transforming these in
as gene symbols into a named a standard
name a common name of a gene and we also
want to understand there
gene so functional annotation what
categories do these genes fall into so I
think we're going to have to look deeper
into this issue in our next lecture but
today I will just show you how to launch
this kind of a pipeline so if we go into
areas of analysis and we go under
utilities now we can upload this output
file that I was just showing you right
so if we we can take a list of genes or
we can take the result of differential
gene expression but for example easy and
the first thing that we can do with this
we don't need any groups we can just use
the annotation function right here to
convert it into gene symbols and gene
ontology categories so output gene
ontology categories we do have a header
right the first row of our table is a
header and now it's interested to know
what is the number of column with gene
transcript edges and it is number one so
we can click OK end and now I'm going to
do alien gene ontology annotation and
run this pipeline so the result of this
I started and you can also start it on
urine so you will get this in a few
minutes because we do have 1,500 genes
let's just take a look at what is the
result of this kind of annotation and so
first of all this is what this is just
an example with 15 genes so just to see
what will be inside of this table what
will be inside is what we used as input
ID right so you can see that what it
does is it takes the NSG and converts it
first of all to a gene symbol so what is
this gene symbol now if we take DCM this
is how the gene will typically be
referenced in in a publication so for
example BC energy we know that it's
called the Koren right so right here is
the corn and we can see what it does so
it's a family of proteins and you can
see Anna what it does and what you can
also find for example our publications
about these genes now we're studying
this in the context of breast cancer so
we can just write in DCM breast cancer
and we can in fact see that this is a
growth factor antagonist for tumor
growth inhibition and it is also has a
prognostic value so for not prognostic
value of stromal the corne expression so
in fact it is an interesting gene in the
context of breast cancer obviously we
have to read through these publications
with a measure of you know kind of
evaluation of the quality but at least
we see that it does have reference and
so this is interesting to us and in the
same way we can go through the other
genes but we can also see here kind of
what this gene belongs to in terms of
its gene description so right here you
see the corn vcn right and you can see
this
you can see the gene ontology domain so
cellular component molecular function
biological process not very informative
but here you also have category
description one so extracellular space
in the different zone mitochondrion etc
so what what is the role that it's
playing this kind of explained right
here and so on you can now go between
these gene ontology categories and start
looking at the different descriptions of
this gene and try to understand what is
the function of this gene and what
doesn't mean when it has a certain level
of expression in one group and another
level of expression in another P so this
is a short way to summarize how we
utilize the results of differential gene
expression or any kind of gene
expression to understand what these
genes do now I think I'm gonna pause
here because this is we've reached the
end of our time but I do want to ask you
if you have any questions before we
leave
okay if there are no questions we will
continue next week with gene set
enrichment analysis looking at the
results of the pipeline and trying to
understand how we can use the genes to
map them on gene sets' gene sets could
be pathways or other gene sets that we
can come up with and then we will talk
about the interpretation how do we
really make sense of this and how we can
demonstrate what we've done we will also
look deeper into normalization so right
now we used non-normalized gene
expression values we will take a look at
how to normalize gene expression values
further between samples and what
difference does it make when we use
normalization thank you again for
joining this session and I'm looking
forward to talking to you again soon
and next week per team can I you use a
gene set of my own for practice in the
pipeline yes you can and pratima I'm
happy to talk to you further on that